aliens
jellyfish
bursting suns
that all is immaterial to me
i don't really want them to be like
anything i want them to be like nothing
else you've seen before
my name is anthony how i'm a kinetic
wind sculptor residing on orchestral in
washington
the unifying element to all of my work
is that the outdoor stuff is all powered
by the wind
i don't have a gallery and haven't had
one for about 30 years
my wife and i have run the whole
business ourselves
without agents or galleries or
consultants most of the people that
see my work see it on youtube videos
a large scale piece will generally start
at say 45 000 50 000 and go up to
400 000 if it's a really big sculpture
but that's the kind of a piece that
takes a long time to make and extracts a
lot of physical
ability out of me
what i'm trying to do with the work is
cause people to stop
whatever thought process
they have in their head
and just for a moment experience
a different kind of reality maybe more
meditative
they work they take people out of there
whatever
nonsense is going on in their heads puts
them in a different place
it's a feeling you get when you see
something that is very beautiful or
unusual that's what i'm trying to do
with the work
you